primarily in um
and we're looking at performance all the
way from the client none of the server
just kind of optimizing as much of it as
we can
yeah i'm john mccutchan and i work in
the dark vmt
focusing on performance so i'm really
just here for the currywurst
all right so we're going to do a trip
down
memory lane and talk about uh managing
memory
at female scale
so you know my gmail attachment gig of
ram you've got like 24
mags on your machine actually i just got
64.
so you've got 64 gigs on your machine
what's the problem well my grandmother's
program is for
well that's a few problems she might
need a new computer
um or you know we can fix this problem
so um you know when it comes down to the
age-old performance versus memory
trade-offs
nine times out of ten developers will
achieve performance because really what
you want to do is give yourself
or your users the best experience
possible and you know having a nice fast
responsive ad is really what you're
after so you know
using a little bit of memory when we
think that we have modern machines with
lots and lots of memory
it's easy so just to be clear you're
saying that
you know the assumption is that you can
use as much memory as you want and
performance is just gonna get better
because you can cache a little bit
that's the typical thinking exactly
but um
though we didn't know you know how often
this is happening we have a lot of users
we didn't know what percentage of users
were experiencing memory problems
but we had a lot of analysis from our
friends and family
and then we kind of started explaining
around a little bit we tried to see like
if we do common actions compose
messages read messages delete stuff you
know
how common is it for memory to grow
right performance deductions and is it
doing
growing uncontrollably um so we started
to look at some tools as well we were
using the chrome dev tools but really
they didn't never
were intended to scale to applications
that were as big as gmail gmail has
become
quite large over the years and so you
know we'd start using it and
the devtools would crash so this is a
problem yeah
and you know it turns out that this is
not just gmail's problem or any other
large web apps problem because really
chrome
will put multiple tabs in the same
process so if one
tab crashes and runs out of memory then
all of the tabs that are in that process
will
will crash as well so even like smaller
web apps that you know are just static
pages of text could be sharing a render
process with chrome
with gmail and they could all crash so
this is a problem that you know we
wanted to fix
on behalf of all web apps yeah
all right but so before we can really
dig into chrome dev tools
and uh get to the bottom of this problem
let's go back to basics
and um talk about how
memory management is uh done behind the
scenes for you in javascript
so we'll talk about some core concepts
like how are values like variables
properties all the things that are like
alive that you interact with
functions everything in javascript how
are they organized in memory
try and come up with the definition of
garbage and then define what a leak is
in a javascript application
so everything in javascript uh is
organized in the value graph
and so you start the value graph at some
root node this is like you can think of
it like document or window
these are things that will never go away
while your page is loaded in the
in the browser aside from the root note
there's also object nodes and this is
just a standard javascript object
um and what makes it distinct from
scalar nodes is that it can actually
reference other values in the graph
scalar nodes are bools numbers things
like that those are always the
end of the end of the value graph
so all values have a retaining path and
this is a very fundamental concept when
it comes to managing memory effectively
in javascript so we look at the green
node here it has two retaining paths
actually
it has the retaining path that starts at
the root note and traverses along that
edge
and the second retaining path starts the
root note and traverses along those two
edges
so if you wanted to free the green node
you would have to cut
both of these retaining paths they would
have to be removed from the graph
otherwise it's going to remain
in memory so let's say we wanted to
remove the red node from the graph
we could start and cut that edge at that
point the red node along with the green
nodes
their garbage they'll be collected
return back to the system you could also
cut this edge or this edge
any of these edges are going to remove
the red node from the graph and as a
javascript application developer you
need to be aware of
you know the retaining paths to these
objects when you're trying to clean it
up
so this is what garbage is garbage is a
value that cannot be reached from the
root note
so if we look at here you can see that
there's these red and green notes here
which the red node is still referencing
the green node they're garbage there's
no way to start at the root node
and find some retaining path that gets
you to these two guys
so garbage collection is like in a very
simple way it's just
finding everything that's still alive
not you're not finding what's dead
you're finding what's still alive what's
still in the graph
and then returning the memory used by
the dead objects back to the system
so in this case these two guys are dead
and we can
you know they'll be returned back after
a garbage collection cycle
so similar to a retained retaining path
there's also retaining size and this is
how much memory you're going to give
back to the system
if you were to cut this value out of the
graph so the yellow node
the yellow node's retain size is the
size of itself plus the size of all of
its descendants that would become
garbage
if the yellow node was pulled out in
this case the l on the green
and we can pull back and we can say that
this new yellow nodes retain size is the
sum of these other
two other nodes and if you pull all the
way back to the root node which you can
never free you can never remove from the
graph
its retain size is everything in your
page
so now that we kind of understand the
very basic
operation of garbage garbage collection
let's look at leaks
so a leak in javascript is just you've
made an error and you've actually left a
retaining path
somewhere in your application maybe
through the dom or through an event
callback or something like that
where you expect some object to have no
more references and be returned to the
system
but it doesn't it's a programmer error
always
so let's look at a really simplistic
version of gmail where we have email and
we're going to make a
div element and put the message inside
the div element
and then we're going to add that div
element to a display list of things that
we're showing on the page
very simplistic but it gets the point
across
so this is a subsection of the value
graph here we have the email
object and it message it references
message and then
message has a special type of native
reference to the dom notes which are
managed independently from javascript
objects
and then we see we have our display and
it has a list of
dom nodes which are being displayed on
the page so sometime later you're done
and you want to clear the display list
and you
you know you remove all the children
from the display but
you've accidentally left that div node
referenced inside your message and the
message is going to be cached
by gmail because we want to cache all
these messages for as long as possible
so we don't have to make network
requests and this kind of behavior you
know on the scale of gmail you leave it
open for a few weeks
suddenly these tiny little leaks start
accumulating and
he's dead
so the basics of javascript memory
management is just everything's inside
of a graph
there's retaining paths and these are
the paths that are holding the values
keeping them alive without a retained
path the value becomes garbage and gets
its retained size is freed back to the
system
so with that out of the way let's talk
about how v8
actually manages your memory so let's
get a little bit more specific a little
bit more low level
and try and help you understand what's
going on when your page gets
interrupted for a garbage collection
so in understanding memory you should
understand where the cost is in
allocating memory and it's not in
actually constructing the object that's
not the expensive part
the expensive part is the collection
phase and we'll see why
momentarily so every time you call new
or do an implicit memory allocation with
like a
an array literal or an object literal
those are actually allocating memory
even though you don't see the keyword
new you're actually
reserving memory from the heap and this
is really cheap
until the memory pool that you're
allocating from is exhausted
at which point the page is paused so
that means your script is just hung
nothing is happening no rendering is
occurring and a garbage collection is
forced because we need to return some
memory back to the system so that it can
satisfy the new request
and this can take milliseconds i know
milliseconds might seem like not very
much but if you think about a frame of
your page and you want something that's
very animation heavy and smooth
you've only got 16 milliseconds if you
have five of them devoted to gc
the user is going to see like some frame
hiccup or something like that so you
have to be careful about
kind of the patterns in which you
allocate memory and
uh try and relate that back to like how
interactive and how the feel of the
application should be
and you know just intuitively every
allocation that you do
brings you closer to this pause there's
no going back every time you take a step
forward
you're getting closer and closer to that
wall where you have to just wait
and then be pulled back and you know
your application can resume
so v8 manages memory in a generational
way and this is a
common uh garbage collection technique
so values are split between young
and old and over time young values are
promoted or tenured up to old values
and so you can this is very like
intuitive like you can just understand
this
simply like young values are things that
you just allocated like a temporary
variable inside the functions is
executing that's a young value
something that you've kept around for
maybe a few minutes
that's going to get moved into the old
heap and that's managed
differently so the
characteristics of a young generation
heap is that
the allocation is really fast collection
is fast because it's small and it's kind
of kept contained
and it's frequently collected when you
use the chrome devtools timeline tool
and you see a gc event nine times out of
ten that's going to be a young space
collection
and you can see here that this
collection took a fraction of a
millisecond
and it freed up about two megs of memory
in contrast the old generation still has
pretty fast allocation
all things being relative but the
collection is much much slower
luckily the collection of old space
happens
very infrequently sometimes never on a
page i mean your page would have to be
around for a while before the whole
space is collected
and parts of the old space collection
actually run concurrently with the
mutator and the mutator is your script
that's your page
so some parts of old space collection
occur while your page is executing
whereas young space is always like an
interruption your page is stopped
frames are dropping everything is just
the user experience is terrible
so why is collecting the young
generation so much faster it really
comes down to a simple metric and that's
the
death rate young objects
are by their very nature very it's very
improbable for them to live a long time
because most of the time
you're just doing some simple
computation on a number and there's an
allocation and then you throw the
reference away and it's out of the graph
almost immediately so it's not going to
stick around and on
average the death rate is about 80
percent was in contrast
old space most things that make it to
old space
have lived for a long time and unless
your application is like completely
doing something
different chances are they're going to
survive an old space collection
so considering that what's going to
cause jank on your page is a young space
collection well let's actually walk
through what's going on when you
allocate memory and then when a
collection occurs
so you can kind of understand when
you're writing your page
how to try and avoid this so the young
generation in v8 is split into two
equally sized halves the two space and
the from space
and when you call new or do an implicit
allocation memory is being reserved from
the tooth space
later on we'll see that during gc the
front space is used and we'll see this
in a moment
assuming your two space is empty it's
all unallocated your page is coming
along and you allocate object a
and then b c and d and everything's
great it's really fast no interruption
the allocation is basically free
it's awesome and then oh you try and
allocate e
and you you don't have enough memory in
size inside the two space to satisfy
this so what happens is your pages
it's kind of backed up e never is
allocated your script is just waiting
there
ready to resume after the gc occurs
so what happens is from and two space
are just swapped
so two space is now empty again and from
space has
all of the objects which you previously
allocated
and then the live values are found again
you don't find dead values you find the
live values
and so b and d in this case are now
they're dead we can return the memory
back to the system and what happens is
basically a and c are allocated again
and they're copied
into the new to space and this copy is
actually where
almost all of the time in a gc is spent
because copying implies i o and that's
that's just expensive relative to cpu
computation these days
so what happens is a and c get copied
there and from space gets cleared
it's free you're just you know you don't
care what's inside that memory anymore
and you can just pretend that it's empty
um and then you can allocate object d
and your page is resumed
so this in a nutshell is what happens
during gc pause when you're looking at
the timeline event you see your page was
paused for two milliseconds
this just occurred and of course we're
looking at a very small scale on the
slides but in something like gmail
i mean there's maybe hundreds of
thousands of objects that have to be
walked and copied that survive
and you know and then there's also the
tenure where you get copied from young
space to old space
so intuitively you have to understand
that each allocation moves you closer
there is no going back
every time you allocate something you're
inching your page closer to that pause
um and you know collection collections
pause your application
it leads to jank users just think like
oh this page is kind of like low quality
maybe they don't want to come back so
you want to minimize this as much as
possible
all right so now we're going to talk a
little bit about tools and techniques
you've got the background down so let's
talk about
what we actually did in gmail so first i
said we were starting out from nothing
we didn't know how
common this problem was so we wanted to
collect some measurements from our users
so to do this we used the window
performance memory
api and we collected this returns three
values
returns the js heap size limit which is
the maximum amount of memory that can be
allocated
um before the he's dead gym and then the
total js heap size which is the total
amount of memory that has been allocated
so far
including the free space and then the
used js heap size which is actually the
amount of
live memory being allocated so is the
total
like that's the high water mark that's
the high water mark yeah including free
space
and then the closer the total gets to
the limit the closer you are to that
use dead gym right so um so what we did
was we collected this data every 30
minutes for gmail users
um and then we aggregated it and then we
could actually see like
how does our average user compare to
like our power users right so we could
see the difference between
you know say um people who are very
active on their email leave it open for
a very long time
get hundreds of messages a day versus
like the people who
log in every once in a while to have one
message a week and you know aren't using
it quite as much
so we could see the difference between
there
and then once we had this data we follow
we took a user
and we followed that person for three
days we kind of watched what happened to
both their memory
and their latency and we saw that over
time as that heap grew
their latencies increased as well and so
this fits with the idea that
like the heaps getting bigger there's
more gcs more things are surviving
right so like every message click to
open a message was taking longer than it
did when you had the smaller heap
so that was really interesting for us
because it turned out that more memory
doesn't always equal better performance
so now we knew that we had a problem but
we needed to figure out how to fix it so
for that we turned to the chrome dev
tools
so the first thing we like to do is to
use the the memory timeline
and using the memory timeline you can
perform a set of actions and watch in
real time
so this graph in particular shows the
number of dom nodes that are allocated
and we know that the number of dom nodes
corresponds directly to
how much memory is being used by the
page so as we performed a bunch of
actions we could see the number of
dominoes grow
growing and then we can force the
garbage collection and you expect to see
that
number drop right and if you pick an
action that you expect
not to result in that increase in memory
then you should expect to see that
the number of dom nodes drop down to
your baseline so we found that
if we do this particular action a bunch
of times and then
collect garbage and it didn't reach the
baseline turns out we have a leak
but now what so for this we turn to the
object tracker and this is live as of
chrome 29
and this will actually allow you to
perform actions in your in your app
and live see a live tracker of
allocated objects so it'll take heap
snapshots periodically as you're
performing these actions
and then you can see the deltas between
each periodic heap snapshot
and be able to figure out what new
objects are in the heap at any given
time
so up here at the top of the object
tracker there's color-coded bars
the blue will indicate live objects and
the gray will
indicate objects that were allocated and
are no longer live
and so you'll actually see over time
blue bars go gray
right right as they're collected they'll
turn gray
and then at the top you can kind of
expand or make your windows smaller to
see
exactly the difference in at a
particular period in time
and then down below is the regular heat
profile contents and
this is you know the heat profiler
that's been in devtools for quite a long
time
but here you can see exactly the
contents of whatever window you happen
to be looking at
so i think um it's probably better done
with a demo
so i we wrote you know a very simple
mail
like app um just like gmail we cache
messages for better performance so we
really want to not have that network
request right when you hit a message to
open it so we want to cache it
in the browser and make sure that when
you click on it it just has to display
it
so in this particular example we have a
cache size of five messages so this
means that we should never have more
than five messages
resident in memory at any given time so
let's check it out
all right
all right so let's bring up the dev
tools
all right so first here we'll start with
the timeline let's
get this up here a little bit so you
guys can see it and we'll make sure the
dom node count is being displayed and
we'll turn off the others so we don't
have quite as much noise so we'll start
it
let's grow through these messages
and collect some garbage
keep going
collect some more just to make sure and
then we'll go ahead and stop it
so we can widen this window
see exactly what happened did i miss the
collection
okay let's like restart this we see that
you know it's it's going up with each
time i click
the amount of number of dom nodes uh
let's go
click this guy did we get it one more
time okay
so we see at the top there's a running
timeline in the blue line and that
can show you um overall what's happening
and then we'll click this again and
let's go ahead and stop this
okay so if we widen this window we can
see the whole timeline here
we see a little drop when we collected
garbage but it didn't drop all the way
to the baseline and this is something
that we expect we expect it
once the cache is full we expect it to
drop back to the baseline with every
five messages
and it didn't look like it did that so
from now let's move over to
the object tracker profiler and we're
gonna go ahead and refresh this tab
so we'll start with a clean slate you
really want to do this in an incognito
window as well so that you don't have
any extensions that you may have
installed in your browser affecting your
performance in your memory
yeah actually so if you have an
extension loaded and we all do
that all the objects that the extension
creates will show up inside the heap
profile
right so incognito tab is always
recommended yep
keep things clean so we've refreshed
we're starting with a clean slate so
we're going to
go ahead and start recording
and let's scroll through these messages
again
and as you see i'm clicking to the next
message these messages are being loaded
and they're blue they're live and then
let's go back down
you see some of these are turning gray
they're no longer in the cache
so let's stop it and
as i told you the message cache is five
and
it looks like i have more than five blue
bars or blue bars here right so we have
more than five messages sticking around
for some reason or another
so we can go and see any particular
allocation and i expect like these ones
down here on the left
the old ones should have been flush from
the cache by now but they're not
so i can click on one of them and it'll
zoom in to just
the delta at that heap snapshot and show
me now down below
what's still live and here we can expand
it and if i click on one of these guys
down below at the bottom you can see the
retaining tree which is what john went
over in the graph
earlier so this will show you this can
help you find bugs because what
was happening here was that we were
saving a reference to every third
message in our cache
and that reference was actually never
removed and so
these messages could not be garbage
collected and so you would have seen
that from the retaining path here
so
all right so was it really worth it
i'd say so this is the stats that we
were collecting from window performance
memory api
and this is over a period of about a
year
so we started out really high the blue
bar was our 99th percentile this is
where the power users were
and um their memory footprints were huge
and the delta between like the 99th
percentile and the median
was was pretty big so over time we
started fixing
identifying these leaks using the
techniques we showed you
as well as just making sure that we were
allocating memory
in a reasonable fashion you see a couple
of
bumps in the blue line there um
they're most obvious in the blue line
but they actually showed up everywhere
and these were actually
regressions in v8 so that were bugs in
in the va garbage collection they were
actually bugs yeah so
um by collecting this data though we
could give them feedback and say you
know this doesn't look right this is
something that
gmail didn't change a whole lot in this
time frame and we're seeing these huge
problems and
um so we were able to get them to fix it
so that's pretty amazing
so really um this is a call to action so
we showed you that
the bigger the footprint the more you
see these pauses the more you'll
you'll be able to see them in your
actual application performance so these
latencies were going up
these pauses were actually affecting our
use
so the traditional memory versus
performance it's not
as traditional as one might think yep so
you should
really ask yourself these questions i
mean how much memory is your page using
do you know
i mean lorena knows exactly how much
memory gmail is using
and brought it down by a massive amount
then you should all be doing this on
your pages because it just
improves the feel of the application
pages are becoming really animation
heavy
and it's awesome but every little gc
pause that occurs during an animation
is going to make your user think uh it's
not the highest quality
so and like if you look at your browser
you know a lot of times at the top of
the bar
you'll see like 50 tabs chrome is not
going to fork you know
50 or 100 render processes so they're
going to end up in the same process
you kind of want to make sure that just
for your own sanity as well as
your users who are you know browsing to
multiple sites at the same time
they're having a good experience and you
know is your page leak free
um gmail wasn't i mean there was some
issues where
over time some common operations were
leaking probably tiny amounts of memory
but
if you want your page to be kind of an
application and your end user is
expected to spend a lot of time with it
these tiny leaks add up and they're not
just
you know chewing up memory as we've
shown it also just decreases the quality
of your site's experience
and you know users these days have very
high expectations for web apps
they've got to perform as good as native
apps
yep so making sure that you're g-seeing
as infrequently as possible like these
tiny little
even fractions of milliseconds can
really add up if you start
allocating more and more memory these
pauses are going to take even longer so
the more data that needs to be copied
from
the from the two space in the from space
like we want to kind of minimize that
and make sure that these pauses are
short
and infrequent so we showed you a bunch
of tools
the api to be able to collect data is
really key
the heat profiler and the continuous
version of the heat profile or the
object tracker
can all be used to both identify and
actually fix
these problems
thank you thanks everybody
so we'll stick around a little bit for
questions outside yeah are there any
questions
or we could do that lots of questions
yes so have you tried approaching the
um problem from another way around so
from my viewpoint it would be so nice to
be able to set
say for instance okay let's see like i
said like four megabyte
budget for my page and basically that we
would be able to like see it okay like
given this like crappy phone that i'm
like sort of trying to simulate
okay this is how often it would be run
the garbage collector would it be
possible for instance like have a
uh writable properties for this windows
performance
i i don't see why it couldn't be i mean
you're right certain devices are very
constrained by memory like a desktop
machine these days is pretty
massive but yeah i think that's a good
idea yeah
okay one more over here first of all i
want to say it was a very good
presentation
i really liked the slides on the garbage
collection um
my question is do the chrome developer
tools show external memory allocations
from things like typed arrays or buffers
and nodejs
are they counting against retained size
do you know um i believe typed array
should show up yep
um and certainly like dom nodes and
things like that which are external
allocations
are there as well yeah yeah all right
thanks
all right so i think we're going to keep
this track rolling so that we don't get
behind
you guys can catch up with these guys at
the break if you have any more questions
so stay tuned and our next speaker will
be up shortly thanks
thanks everyone
you